today on stick to football that's right
a little bit of a different voice to
bring it into the show today no Matt he
is out sick I will be riding solo for
this show unless I decide to randomly
maybe call some people or someone pops
in this studio but a really good show
planned for you today coming off a great
weekend down in Atlanta with
Johnsonville with Sean Alexander at the
SEC Championship we had a really good
time we saw some magic from Joe burrow
and we saw LSU officially clinched that
number one spot for the college football
playoff and speaking of LSU the Heisman
finalists are out and that will be
highlighted by Joe burrow Joe burrow
very much expected to take this trophy
home it might be surprising if anyone
votes for anyone but Joe burrow in that
number one spot for the Heisman Trophy
but he will not be in New York alone he
will be joined by Jalen hurts from
Oklahoma chase young from Ohio State
hashtag defense for Heisman and Justin
fields from Ohio State so the Buckeyes
getting to players as Heisman finalist
here no Jonathan Taylor which I think is
really interesting I think if Wisconsin
had won the Big Ten I think Taylor would
have gotten an appearance there and at
the end of the day you could argue he
still deserved one it's a tough break
for Taylor who finishes right now with
over 1,900 rushing yards and what is
expected to be his final season at
Wisconsin 21 rushing touchdowns those
rushing yards and rushing touchdowns are
both second in the country so phenomenal
season for him a guy that we're going to
talk about non-stop in this really
really good running back class but when
you look at this Heisman group I mean we
have to start with Joe burrow and what a
magical season for him and this doesn't
have to be as a girafft prospect because
there's plenty of time for that there's
no doubt about that he will be a 23 year
old quarterback prospect expected to be
the number one overall pick to the
cincinnati bengals who as this list goes
on and on the old good old tank Athan
calm it doesn't really seem like anyone
but the bengals maybe the Giants are in
the picture but the bengals should have
that number one pick and back to burrow
I mean 48 passing touchdowns this year
only six interceptions he's thrown for
fourth
715 yards LSU is undefeated LSU is
projected to win the national title
that's you know the next big hurdle here
for burrow and really a gigantic not a
gigantic hurdle as they get Oklahoma in
the first moving up to the first seed as
well get Clemson and Ohio State in the
other game this is an LSU team that
should steamroll Oklahoma it would be a
shocking upset if they didn't and a lot
of that is due to burrow and the steps
he's taken this year this is a really
really good LSU offense whether you have
chase and Jefferson that wide receiver
whether you have Clyde Edwards to layer
it running back a good offensive line
that has some veterans and I think when
you look at just what burrow has done as
a whole in this offense thanks to some
reconstructing from Joe Brady there he's
thrived they've really moved into a
modern era offense a lot of spread
concepts it's a very different LSU team
and it's helped burrow take the next
steps and why when you look at what's
been a magical season for him
highlighted by some incredible plays I
mean when you look at the SEC
Championship just his ability to move in
and outside the pocket throw the
football down the field even some of the
drops were some of his best throws of
the season on that Saturday evening I
think it's been an incredible season for
Joe burrow it's only gonna get better
for him for here on out assuming they
can you know win in the semis and
possibly win a national title but most
importantly for him to go number one
overall but let's talk about some of the
other guys that will be in New York
Jalen Hertz goes to Oklahoma kind of
redeemed his career as a quarterback a
guy that Wella Bama wanted to stay they
wanted him to potentially move to
running back he says listen I'm not
doing that I'm a quarterback I'm going
with the best quarterback guru in the
country and that's Lincoln Riley and for
Hertz I think we've seen a little bit of
everything this year I think there's
times where he's shown that he's still
obviously not a perfect quarterback
prospect I think the arm strength is
just okay at times I think he tries to
play hero ball a lot there is some
questionable decision-making at times
he's not a runner like a lot of people
have classified him to be in the mold of
a player like Lamar Jackson or deshaun
Watson but he's still a guy
that moves very well and can run the
football and for him once again this
Oklahoma team that's 12 and 1 right now
he does deserve to be there
because he's taking an offense where
there was high expectations when you
look at what Baker Mayfield and Kyler
Murray did both winning Heisman trophies
both being number one overall picks
under Lincoln Riley now Jalen Hertz is
the guy that he won't win the Heisman he
won't go number one but he had a
phenomenal season for Oklahoma he
improved his draft stock by a couple of
rounds which is pretty significant and
somebody that should go to the Senior
Bowl to really cement his stock and to
show teams that he wants to be out there
to compete that he has a lot left to
prove that he can work with coaching
staffs and coaching staffs at the Senior
Bowl that should have interesting
quarterbacks especially if the bengals
is one of them it's going to end listen
coaches talk to each other so you're not
auditioning they're just for one or two
teams you're really auditioning for
everyone so once again a really good
season for jaylen Hertz and it's
exciting to see him there but the guy
that I'm happiest for out of this group
even more so than Joe burrow is chase
young because for a defensive player to
get that Heisman invite and defy the
odds
it's truly impressive as this has turned
into really a quarterback and running
back award it's either the best
quarterback or best running back on the
best team in the country and I
understand why Joe burrow was gonna win
this award you can't convince me that
he's not worthy of it he is the guy if
anyone doesn't vote for him they're
absolutely insane but chase young
missing two games due to a whacky fluky
suspension 16 and a half sacks he plays
in the big ten he leads the country in
sacks he's the best offensive player in
the country he's the best draft prospect
in this entire class chase Young
deserves to be there and I hope this
sets a trend that more defensive players
do get the recognition they deserve
where I could almost make the argument
that there should be at least one
defensive player invited to the Heisman
the Heisman ceremony every single year
whoever the best whoever had the best
offensive season in the country should
go and last year that would have been a
guy like Josh Allen from Kentucky that
had a ton of sacks I believe just maybe
two less then chase young did
and I think it's something where they
need to show if they want this award to
be recognized as the best player in
college football then you do need to
have a defensive player represent their
because otherwise it's just going to be
viewed as a quarterback or running back
award and then you need to change the
definition of the award so a really good
job here getting him there I don't think
that was a very difficult decision and
one that also wasn't a difficult
decision is probably having his teammate
Justin fields there when you look at the
numbers quarterbacks are producing in
this ryan day offense whether it's duane
Haskins and now justin fields it makes
you laugh to think that it could have
been Joe burrow even last year or even
this year but Justin fields a lot of
people probably don't even realize this
he's thrown 40 touchdowns and one
interception a 40 to 1 touchdown to
interception ratio that is unbelievably
hard to do and I think for a quarterback
that's in his first year as a starter
it's even more impressive and he ran for
10 touchdowns so you're talking about 50
total touchdowns for a first-year
starter now this is an offense that is
constructed wonderfully I think it's
well coached
I think JK Dobbins is one of the best
running backs in the country they have a
really deep group of wide receivers
especially with a lob a and Hill they've
done a fantastic job
they have tight ends that can contribute
in the pass game the offensive line is
not only well coached but well developed
no matter how many bodies they lose
every year but when you start to open
the door for Heisman talk next year
it starts with Justin Fields and Trevor
Lawrence is finished this year on a high
note Trevor Lawrence is right in that
picture as well there's no doubt about
that but I like that Justin fields will
be there because listen Joe burrow Jalen
Hertz
chase young they're gonna be playing in
the NFL next year to have a future a now
and future college star on that podium
is really really good for college
football and was the right call one more
thing from the around the league our
opening segment here obviously the
Patriots the tape against event with
Cincinnati a lot of different opinions
on this but at the end of the day New
England has released the statement that
they are taking a responsibility for
this now how this goes down is
essentially this video crew was not part
of the football operations and for what
a lot of people that means is they were
most likely in external freelance crew
hired for the media department working
on this feature about a scouting feature
now there will be people that don't
believe that there will be people that
do whatever side you sit on I think
there it's pretty hard to ultimately
pick a side without having your hands on
that videotape and how obvious it was
and how long it was shot for they're
saying the first quarter they're saying
it was shot of the team on the sidelines
of signals that's all to be determined
by the NFL but I think the most
noteworthy thing we can discuss right
now is that New England is getting out
in front of it and saying listen while
this wasn't a video operations team in
our football department this was a team
hired crew that made an honest mistake
and whether you believe that's honest is
another question but they are owning it
I think the question people will now
wonder as the NFL does their
investigation of how severe this is will
be the punishment and to get out in
front of this that can range from
something as simple as a fine of maybe
fifty thousand two hundred thousand two
hundred fifty thousand it could range
all the way to a first-round pick it
depends how significant and we have
evidence of things like this in the past
to point to it can maybe only be a
third-round pick there's a lot of
different ways this can go
there's no conclusion right now but it's
very interesting once again that New
England didn't necessarily fight this
maybe it's the right option for them to
go if they truly think it was just an
accident and it can reduce the overall
penalty well this is a story that's not
going to go away anytime soon
once again all right we're gonna take a
break here when I get back we're gonna
do a head coaching candidates preview
all the top head coaching candidates and
one team that'll be looking for one to
pair with them
all right I am back here still getting
used to being so low god I actually miss
Matt even though I've spent the entire
season with him but gonna break down all
the top head coaching candidates I know
we've done a little bit of this on
fixing the team's gonna wait till Matt's
back to obviously do that together to
continue that segment but a little
overall run-through as it becomes clear
what teams are gonna have openings what
guys are expected to get interviews and
I think we need to start with the
elephant in the room and that is Lincoln
Riley and when you look at this
situation Lincoln Riley has probably
been the hottest name in coaching
circles for well over a year now there
were teams that checked in with Lincoln
Riley last year to see if there was any
interest in getting him out of Oklahoma
there was none at the time if you asked
around a lot of different people whether
it's area Scouts near that Oklahoma team
whether it's front office executives
they will tell you the general feeling
with Lincoln Riley is the only team he
would be willing to listen to at this
moment is the Dallas Cowboys now the one
issue that existed before this NFL
season was nobody really thought that
Dallas Cowboys job would open up in the
near future this is a loaded roster they
got a zekiel Elliott back into the fold
dak Prescott was taking the necessary
steps to be their franchise quarterback
which he certainly has and the Jones
family has always been very patient and
very loyal to Jason Garrett now a lot
has changed this year a couple
embarrassing losses for the Dallas
Cowboys whether you want to start with
the one against the New York Jets the
one against the Bears on Thursday Night
Football I think when you look at it
it's come down to it where it almost
feels like the inevitable of this year
unless they miraculously make a Super
Bowl run that Jason Garrett will be
moving on or I should say the Jones
family will be moving on from him and
looking for a head coach for the first
time in a very very long time and I
think the guy in all of this has to be
Lincoln Riley I think we've heard Obon
Meyers name thrown into the
I know on this show specifically we've
said listen Matt rules down there Matt
rules in North East guy but he's down
there at Baylor right now I mean you can
get a good look at him whenever you want
what he's done with that program which
he's done a phenomenal job and that's
the second program he's rebuilt starting
with temple doing it at Baylor he
actually has some NFL experience he was
on the Giants coaching staff but when
you go down the list and you look at
Urban Meyer Urban Meyer's the football
legend does he want the NFL at this
point of his life and if you're the
Dallas Cowboys this always feels like a
job to me now at least especially with
the Corps they've put in place are you
hiring a guy that's a band-aid hire
Urban Meyer is will be 56 years old next
year and has had has walked away twice
due to overall health issues I think
when it comes down to it that's not the
guy for the Cowboys I think the the
system they built in place the stability
they have whether it's the Jones family
working with a phenomenal phenomenal
personnel man in Wilma clay who is
essentially the GM of the team and the
roster they've built with a lot of young
pieces you have tank Lawrence signed up
for the long term you're gonna get dak
Prescott done you have Asik Elliott you
have a good offensive line even if the
offensive line I'll need some retooling
in a couple years at the end of the day
it's a very very good group I think you
go get the guy that's the young guy that
can really build a dominant offense
Lincoln Reilly's 36 years old he won't
turn turned 37 to a week one of the NFL
season next year if he has any interest
which there's been a lot of buzz that he
does in possibly leaving Oklahoma for
this job
you opened the checkbook and you get it
done it's as simple as that I think he'd
take the offense to a next level I think
dak Prescott would absolutely thrive
under him especially if you have a duo
of Amari Cooper and Michael Gallup there
Ezekiel Elliott has has not been the
same guy this year but he's still a very
very capable starting and running back
probably in the upper tier of backs this
is just a no-brainer to me I don't think
it's a difficult choice I think the
question everyone has to answer is will
take the job and if I'm just going by
gut feeling I think this is a job he
listens to I think it's a really good
opportunity I think it offers the two
most important things that he's looking
for one being a roster that can win NFL
football games and to security he will
get long-term money that it doesn't
matter what happens he will get a
long-term contract where he'll be given
time to build things the way he needs to
and this family the Jones family and
football is one of the most patient
maybe the most patient owners in the
entire league so that that's it for
Lincoln Riley that's the team next up
the New York Giants I guess you could
say some people say a crushing loss on
Monday Night Football this is a good
loss for the Giants you don't want to
fall away from that Chase young
sweepstakes you want that to be the guy
if there is anything we've learned this
year and most of us already knew this
but it has only become more highlighted
and illuminated Pat Shermer can not
coach in the NFL in a game situation
whether it's having no idea how to use
timeouts challenges calling plays at the
right times it's an absolute mess I
think Pat Shermer is a guy that can be
or has been a good offensive coordinator
and good with quarterbacks in this
league I think the problem with the NFL
right now there has become a significant
gray area a very very cloudy situation
of a guy that can run an offense and a
guy that can coach an NFL team and I
think you see it across the league right
now you saw your one already with Zach
Taylor
maybe he'll improve he has plenty of
time to show so you've seen it with Adam
GaSe for years right now I think on the
flip side you've seen two guys that are
NFL head coaches not offensive
masterminds they are NFL masterminds
Kyle Shanahan and Sean McVeigh people
need to distinguish the difference
between those two paths Shermer falls
into the former bucket and the Giants no
needs to go get a CEO of this football
team and that's Matt rule it really is
for me I look at Matt rule he's this
kind of coach that he's coach with the
Giants before once again he's front he's
a northeast guy I think he loved this
job I think it's a direction where it's
not an old man higher for the knee
our Giants but it's also not going
against something the Mars are a little
unwilling to do and that's higher a 30
year old 30 something year old Matt rule
is the perfect guy right in the middle
for the New York Giants that can rebuild
this defense probably be very good build
a very good environment for a young
developing quarterback in Daniel Jones
and he's somebody where if you hire him
the New York Giants are not going to be
in the playoffs next year but with the
amount of losing seasons in dramatic
fashion the Giants are piling up it pays
to be patient and that's why I look at
their situation and really find that
Matt rule is the guy and the next guy is
someone else that I'll constantly be
mentioned for the Giants and would be a
good hire is Ron Rivera and Rivera is
going to get another job next year he is
not gonna have to take a year off like
Mike McCarthy this was not a situation
in Carolina where he lost the team it
was nothing like that it was that a new
owner one his guy wanted new life wanted
to go in a different direction Ron
Rivera will be a highly sought after
candidate and the three guys I've
started with here are probably the top
three guys or three of the top guys
Lincoln Reilly Matt rule Ron Rivera now
the perfect match to me for Ron Rivera
is a team that it is very up in the air
if they will have a vacant head coaching
spot and that is the Cleveland Browns I
checked in with a lot of people this
weekend and they still would be
surprised that Freddy kitchens is fired
now there is a lot of time left there's
a lot of valuating left to do but the
fact that he is a first-year coach the
fact that this was somebody that Dorsey
felt comfortable hiring this is somebody
Baker Mayfield put his name behind they
there is a feeling there that Freddy
kitchens should be given the opportunity
to develop now play-calling is something
that can be taken away from him because
once again
Freddy kitchens falls into the bucket of
a good offensive play caller not an NFL
head coach now if this Browns job does
open up which I believe it should
although once again there is not a ton
of optimism right now that it
necessarily
Ron Rivera is the guy that can come in
and straighten out that situation
especially if he can bring a veteran
offensive coordinator with him for Baker
Mayfield in this offense so once again
Ron Rivera and the Browns I think that's
a match made in heaven we'll see what
happens
number four on this list of head
coaching candidates starting with
somebody from Kyle Shanahan staff
finally this guy deserves it very much
so
Robert Salah the defensive coordinator
of the 49ers this is another guy I feel
very confident will get a job at a
minimum he should get a couple of
interviews and the reason I say he
should get a job is because he will
interview very well
he has great energy he's very good in a
locker room or with executives he's
somebody that's transformed as his
defense Kyle Shanahan did not give up on
him during early struggles in San
Francisco and it's paid off look at what
that young defense has done whether it's
Nick but everybody up front is
phenomenal
Fred Warner at linebacker the veteran
guy I'm Richard Sherman in the secondary
this is a defense that has really really
gelled this year and Sal is the guy that
a lot of people are very high on now the
question with him is as you look across
the league is what team would be willing
to hire a defensive coordinator this is
a league that when it comes down to it
has started to trend in a direction of
young innovative offensive minds some of
them have failed miserably some of them
have worked out phenomenally you look at
Matt Lafleur
Sean McVeigh Kyle Shanahan those guys
are having a lot of success right now we
could be here all day of the guys that
did not and I think when you look at
salla one place that does kind of add up
right now is Jacksonville Jacksonville
is falling into an absolute mess I don't
think they're a team that will sit there
and go we have to hire an offensive guy
as much as they'll be developing Gardner
Minshew for the future most likely I
think sal is somebody that can come in
there that would be willing to go there
ownership is held in very high regard
amongst the league and I think it would
be a fit where he has a lot of pieces on
that young defense a lot of
raph capital to work with that
Jacksonville can eventually get right
back on track now they're gonna have to
wait out the Nick Foles deal which is
always going to be a significant problem
when you look at Yannick in a gock way
that's going to be a situation where can
they find a middle ground and find a way
to extend them or do they have to trade
them for more draft assets but at the
end of the day you need someone to come
in there you need new blood Tom Coughlin
and Doug Marrone they got to move on
from these guys they need new energy and
salah is an energy kind of guy next up
not straying too far we're staying with
the 49ers staff this is Mike Mike
McDaniel
this is Kyle Shanahan's guy this is
always been Kyle Shanahan sky Mike
McDaniel was on that legendary
Washington staff that had Shawn McVeigh
Matt Matt Lafleur McDaniel and Kyle
Shanahan all on the same staff
unbelievable to think about that just
about I think seven years ago or eight
years ago but when you look at McDaniel
he is a run game mastermind an absolute
engineer of the run game now why well
he's been next to the Shanahan's for how
long now and he's somebody that when he
gets brought up in head coaching
conversations the problem was there was
a bit of time where Mike reportedly had
a drinking problem I believe it was
during Atlanta where he was able to
rehab get his life back on track and he
has been you know booze free for quite
some time now for quite a few years and
you look at what this guy he number one
he's loved by players absolutely loved
by players and I think he's universally
very well-liked across the board now
will he light up a room like a guy like
salla or rule or any of those kind of
high energy guys he won't he's not that
kind of guy but is he brilliant
absolutely a brilliant brilliant
Orchestrator of offense and I go to a
franchise that has not been able to
develop a run game for one of the most
underrated quarterbacks of the last
decade that is the Detroit Lions
Matt Stafford he's been hurt this year I
don't know how he does it every year
with absolutely no run
aiding him but I look at what mcdaniel
can do he can come in there they have
pieces on the offensive line they can
get this thing right long term for
Stafford and what's left of his career
where I know there's been a lot of
people saying man can they trade them so
Stafford can go thrive somewhere else
he's only 31 years old right now and I
think for the Lions I think when you
look at it right now you stick with him
obviously and you find a coach that can
help him
Matt Patricia was not that guy that's
the problem here Matt Patricia was not
the coach to aid Matt Stafford Matt
Patricia was the coach to bring in this
very serious culture build this defense
and Stafford carries the offense and I
don't think that's very fair and that's
why if McDaniel can come in an interview
and have the hiring power to get a
defensive coordinator that could be the
head coach of the defense this is a
match that would make a lot of sense for
both sides but it would take a bold hire
from the Lions this would be a bold bold
hire all right next up the Atlanta
Falcons another team that's very
interesting because they have a roster
that can hang with anyone but they have
not been well coached this year they've
been hit by injuries the last couple
years hit by injuries again as they lose
Calvin Ridley for the rest of the season
Julio Jones has been banged up I think
when you look at this though one of the
guys that is going to get interviews
that really deserves a shot here is Greg
Roman for what he's done in Baltimore
with Lamar Jackson what he did in
Buffalo with Tyrod Taylor what he's done
over the years with a lot of offenses
with a lot of mobile quarterbacks now
you're gonna sit there and say well
that's not Matt Ryan but Greg Roman is
not a guy that has to have a quarterback
that can run he's a guy that can help
develop a run game and open up things
for the quarterback in the pass game and
I think when you look at Roman he's
somebody that has been significantly
underrated across the league I'm sure
Rex Ryan firing him on deservingly
probably hurt his reputation a little
bit which was very wrong I believe he
fired him after a game where the bills
scored 31 points and at 400 yards of
offense or something along those line
I just think when you look at Roman for
what he's done with the young
quarterbacks and how he's gone in and
orchestrated teams that could simply
score points and control the football or
hit the big play they could do it both
ways
I think Romans somebody that has to come
up in conversations and when you look at
Atlanta right now I think with how
things have gone with Dan Quinn they
will go back to a guy on offense they
will look for somebody that can come in
much like the Lions should do they have
a veteran quarterback develop the run
game get a team that could score points
again we were just there at
mercedes-benz that is the most
impressive stadium I have ever been to
and they can really try to get the maybe
the greatest show on turf 2.0 here back
it well not back in Atlanta but invented
in Atlanta all right moving down the
line Kevin Stefanski from the Minnesota
Vikings when you look at him this is
someone that's a bit of a mystery guy
right now he's 37 years old he's the
offensive coordinator of a team that is
thriving with Dalvin cook and Kirk
Cousins and good wide receivers he's
somebody that is once again gonna get
interviews somebody that has a lot of
positive reviews the reason I call him a
bit of a mystery man right now is
because the question NFL teams will have
is how much of this offensive
improvement is due to Gary Kubiak being
there in Minnesota that is not to take
away from Stefanski it's not at all he's
done a great job there this year he
really has but teams will sit there and
wonder how much of this is Kubiak or how
much of this is Kubiak mentoring him
because if it's the latter that's fine I
mean all of these guys have come from a
tree of learning from somewhere when you
really look at it I mean McDaniel what
Shanahan is a very very obvious one now
so fan ski working with Kubiak but I go
with the Carolina Panthers in this spot
because I think this is a an owner
that'll be looking to making a young
hire this is an owner that will be bold
and this is an owner that will look
across the league and look at the
numbers and see how success
Minnesota has been on offense and
that'll be something very important to
him now the question you'll have to
bring up with the Panthers is we don't
know what ownership is looking for right
now that's the question because they
just fired a great coach in Ron Rivera
and I'm not saying that was wrong
because you can make the argument
sometimes it's just over for both sides
but at the end of the day when you fire
a really good head coach you are setting
expectations extremely high and that's
why I think it'll be somebody very young
where they'll look for the boom or bust
kind of hire all right last one on this
list
you can't not talk about him because
he's in the news non-stop Mike McCarthy
McCarthy has a reportedly been hiring
coaches this year that are aiding him
and where the NFL is going the general
direction of the league specifically on
offense were the offensive concepts with
offensive personnel McCarthy is not
going to excite a lot of fan bases now I
do think he's somebody that can rebound
I thought he needed a year off from how
I what I heard about his interviews it
seems like he was a little bit
checked-out a little bit just past this
time and whether that means he needs to
hang it up for good or he just needed
the year off to recharge refresh and sit
back and look at everything from afar is
what teams are gonna be wondering but if
you've been listening to this entire
segment that's a lot of jobs opening up
for head coaches and there will always
be guys that stay and wait and when you
look at these eight jobs the eighth
being who I'm gonna attach Mike McCarthy
to is the Washington Redskins somebody's
gonna be left in a tough spot and when
you look at Washington right now they
could potentially be one of the least
attractive options because how things
have generally gone there under
ownership of the last decade what makes
them a potentially attractive option is
to
things money and power if Bruce Allen's
gone the doors open wide for this job
because somebody can come in there and
be the CEO of the Redskins football
operations and that means the draft that
means the hiring of the staff that means
basically signing free agents and doing
the trades as they please and I think
when football teams often do that or
ownership it does that they gear towards
an experienced guy and sometimes it
fails Tom Coughlin but once in a while
or it definitely has its success I think
we've especially seen it Andy Reid is
really a CEO of the Chiefs Veatch does a
great job over there Mike Moore Ganzi
does a great job over there they've had
great Scouts but Andy is very very
influential in a lot of the decisions
the teams make so for Mike McCarthy I
think he would love one of those jobs I
think an owner like Schneider will lean
towards an older guy and we're gonna
talk about that football team non-stop
because they're one of the most
interesting for our show because they
fall into the category of building
building from scratch what's the future
of Dewayne Haskins can they get chase
young what does this defense look like
what does the staff look like how did
they draft this year
without a second round pick what did
they get for Trent Williams but when you
look at Mike McCarthy
I think teams will at least listen to
him and see if he's recharged and he's
gonna be one of the interesting coaching
interviews across this wild head
coaching cycle
all right we're back to close out the
show here with your draft on draft
questions this first one from damn supe
based solely on catching ability is it
wrong to rate CD Lam higher than Jerry
Judy absolutely not I think in terms of
just tracking the football and strong
hands CD Lam is on another planet
compared to Jerry Judy I really do now
where these guys will be evaluated on
across the board is Judy's gonna run
probably significantly faster I think
Judy will be a four three five player
I think CD lamb will be a four or five
four kind of player that's that's a lot
of time when you're evaluating these
guys as potential top 10 picks after the
catch I think they're different players
I think Judy is electric with a one cut
and go kind of move and I think lamb is
tougher I think he'll run through you
and because tacklers fear how much he
runs through people they're hesitating
and now you're seeing him Juke spin
stutter stiff-arm I think when you look
at them both it's interesting because
CDs gonna be a no for a lot of old
school scouts on the fact of his running
or lack thereof speed I think that's
absolute [ __ ] and I think that I
actually think lamb is the best wide
receiver in this class right now and I
love Jerry Judy I would take either of
them in the top ten in the blink of an
eye I think Judy is somebody that's
safer because he's quicker and it's a
better route runner and he played in a
tougher conference I think CD is a weird
outlier like Hopkins was where he's not
gonna run by a lot of people but he will
physically wear you down he will catch
the ball over you he will snatch the
ball away from you he'll go over the
middle of the field and in the fourth
quarter he's the guy that's going to
punch you in the mouth on his way to the
end zone to make a play so and actually
think something with lamb that I haven't
talked about enough is something we talk
about in the show every year you need to
factor and build up speed the 40 time is
going to cater to guys that have great
acceleration CD is somebody when he gets
to that second leg and he builds up
momentum he has
year that is good enough a gear where he
can run away from people in the open
field so I love the question because it
is a truly a trait specific question CV
Lam is is just way better at the aspects
of catching the football which is just
tracking in strong hands right now we've
seen some drops from Judy this year for
how all of his greatness we've seen some
drops and you see drops from great wide
receivers all the time alright next up
from Billy Mustafa what's the
possibility of a straight trade of true
Biscay for cam does that make any sense
or was it dreamland so this was a longer
question from Billy that I condensed but
his overall point was that it would give
true Biscay a chance to go back to
Carolina and you know maybe develop in a
situation where there's less there's
more patience and for cam it's a place
to go where you know a team that wants
to win now and needs more from the
quarterback position I don't think this
trade has a chance
I think the Panthers hold cam in higher
regard I think the money would not
really they wouldn't want to take on
true Biscay and I think for the Bears
they're gonna have to figure out cap
problems of their own
and I think when you look at this
overall situation though if cam has
moved it could be a trade actually where
cam is moved and maybe some money is
swapped in the deal but on the flip side
the Panthers get a good asset whether
that's a second or first round pick I
don't think they'll move him just to
move him is the overall point and I
think wisely so the Panthers want to see
if cam can get healthy and get right
after being off this year because when
cam is healthy and cam is right you have
yourself a top 12 quarterback in the
league so for the for the Panthers they
don't want to just dump him and for the
Bears they have a fascinating situation
on their hands at quarterback this next
one from Wyatt with the way Jonathan
Taylor
deandre Swift and Travis etn are playing
why don't they get top ten love / buzz
like Zeke Gurley and sake wanted that's
a great question and I think it's a mix
of two things one I think nobody in this
class will have the grades that the NFL
had on say qualm Barkley Ezekiel Elliott
and Todd Gurley
whether you agree or disagree with that
is another conversation I've actually
think for meaty Andres Swift will be
pretty close to Gurley and maybe Zeke se
Kwan will say quantal great out higher
than anyone he will but teams are
waiting on running back they I mean you
look at the Giants right now for all se
Kwang's greatness you almost can't
justify taking a running back in the top
top couple picks anymore it's so hard to
do and another reason they're not
getting top ten love buzz is because
they're cancelling each other out teams
are looking and they sit there and they
go well if the on Jerry Swift and
Jonathan Taylor go in the first round we
don't care because we like Travis TTN
and JK Dobbins or not J Harris or
Keyshawn Vaughan I could do this I could
sit here all day and give you nine
million running backs of why they won't
take one in the first round I actually
think the trickle effect is gonna be so
big that it's gonna go into the third
round we saw David Montgomery fall to
the third round last year and if the
Raiders didn't the Raiders were in love
with Josh Jacobs and Josh Jacobs is a
great player the long-term health
concerns were the one thing teams were
wondering about I don't think Jacobs
would have went in the first round if it
wasn't for Oakland having three
first-round picks so I think Swift can
sneak in Taylor might sneak in etn and
and najhe and JK Dobbins should go in
the second round if one of them sitting
there in the third I wouldn't even be
the slightest bit surprised it's such a
stacked visit we just saw Boston Scott
on Monday Night Football become a thing
Boston Scott so that's why teams will
sit there and go we're not using our
first round there's no best team
builders right now if it's not an elite
player they're getting premium positions
with their top picks because those
premium positions are gone by the top as
outside of the top 50 alright last one
of the day from Tommy tankers if you had
to pick the best offense defense special
teams and coaching staff to make an
ultimate team of the college football
team the playoff teams who are you
picking
so it's tricky because you look at the
offense and you could take any of the
four I'm gonna go with LSU because I
think burro is playing with the
confidence right now that is unrivaled
by any of the other three quarterbacks I
think that the wide receiver core of LSU
is unbelievable Clemson is very close as
a whole and they've won a national title
this group that's what's insane t
Higgins Justin Ross travis ET n it's a
now thing if I was taking one for the
NFL I would take Clemson but right now I
think LSU is playing with such an absurd
confidence that I'd go with their
offense when you look at the defense's
you could rule out Oklahoma right away I
think I'll go with Ohio State because I
think chase young can take over games I
think Jeff accout is the best defensive
back in the entire country by a mile and
I think that's all that matters when you
have a star on the front end star on the
back end they have experience they did
leave the middle of the field wide open
a couple of times in the Big Ten
championship but this is a very good
team and I think this is the best
defense in the college football playoff
there were special teams it's a bit of a
toss-up for me it really is I don't know
which direction I would go with that
route now you have to like I love CD
lamb as a punt returner so I would maybe
lean towards Oklahoma as crazy as that
is but you can go with any of the
special teams units here and I think
that when you look at it you know when
you go back to the conversation of the
offenses and defenses it's so close that
I mean it's so ridiculously close and
another thing on special teams with
Oklahoma is that their kicker has been
you know they've had they've been very
reliable I think at times this year
where I think you're looking for real
reliability you don't have a kicker in
this right now I don't think we're like
Rodrigo from Georgia
or the I think the Iowa kicker special
teams is tough I'm like spinning in
circles here with that one it's very
very difficult and maybe somebody have a
special teams moment and you could just
wait and see so so I lied one bonus
question here because we do have some
time before we close out the show Dan
Keefer says who are the early 2020
defense for Heisman picks
I mean Thibodeaux on Oregon has lit the
world on fire Stingley from LSU for a
corner is gonna get some love which is
really really exciting I think those are
the 1a and 1b kind of guys going into
the year now is when we catch up on more
summer tape there's always somebody that
stands out it's been fun doing it for
two years right now because I remember
going into 2018 and Oliver was the guy
and then Quinn and Williams had a great
year but ed Oliver was the guy it's like
man could we get this guy in the Heisman
campaign it was a tough year at Houston
to do that I think this year it was
always about chase young it really was
and it was actually really exciting to
see him legitimately be at number one in
the conversation at one point in time of
the overall Heisman rankings and going
to New York now so it's one of my
favorite things we've done on the show
because it's unique and I think we'll
actually have a list of our top five as
we do every year probably closer to June
but Thibodeaux is the guy just because
the sack numbers count so much when
you're getting after the quarterback
that's what's going to get you on the
podium so that's a tradition that's not
going to go away from the show for
everyone that stuck around today really
appreciate you hanging with me matt is
expected to be back for the Friday show
Melo will be back on for the Friday show
we'll have a really fun one as we talk
about how this playoff is breaking down
of course we'll get you a top five maybe
we'll even sneak in a lot of our NFL
talk then since we didn't fix a team or
do a ton of NFL Talk overall in this
show of what's going on week to week so
I will catch you guys Friday thanks
again see you later